the Joe Rogan experience it didn't get
really ramped up until Barack Obama in
like 2010 when it was clear that Barack
Obama was a neoliberal corporatist who
was going to do the bidding of the war
machine and Wall Street and Big Pharma
which is why when the Democrats got
control of government they had the
presidency the Senate filibuster proof
Senate for a few months and they had the
Congress and the House and they didn't
pass single-payer or even a public
option what do we get we got a
right-wing healthcare plan anyway which
is a giveaway to the pharma and health
insurance companies that left out 28
million [ __ ] people and infuriated
small business owners infuriated people
that were that had a small practice that
there were doctors and you know and all
sorts of people that it was better than
what we had it was a bad solution it
wasn't a solution what it was was a
solution for the pharmaceutical
companies and the health insurance
company was it better than what we had
well because you before there was
pre-existing conditions and you couldn't
get coverage so then they were supposed
to so now you could always get coverage
so that part was better those yeah you
can get covered even if you had an issue
right right so then you could go and you
could go on in exchange and stuff like
that I didn't ever had to do that I
always got through my wife's employer
I'd always had my health insurance right
and by the way having health insurance
is doesn't really mean that much I got
really sick and what you were talking
about this before this was that's the
different thing but I got had a an
illness so they couldn't diagnose for a
few years and it almost killed me right
and it wasn't it was called
hypophosphatemia osteomalacia whoa don't
be on late-night TV like one of those
commercials do you have Oscar fantasies
about you but side effects on osius side
effects include death ah that's a it's a
bone disease so my bones were admitting
I have the bottom line is my bones were
just I was having a bone disintegration
whoa so yeah I used to be much taller I
know that sounds funny right it's
actually true is that true when we met I
was taller than you get the [ __ ] out of
here come I'll tell were you I was
around five ten and you'd shrank to five
eight I'm a little little under five
eight
wow that's crazy yeah so I know right
and when that happened I was gonna kill
myself
try stretch yourself out yes get one of
those things they use medieval torture
devices so I'm one of those guys who if
I want something no matter what price I
have to pay physical whatever I'll pay
it and I'll do I don't get that thing I
want right like I'll get it but this
book Guinea you mind elaborating on this
thing yeah so so I couldn't fix it by
stretching it good and it's just talking
about that but but so what does it do to
you it's making your bones shrink yes
yes oh it gives you a ste Oh per OSIS
and then my bones got hollow like an old
lady Wow and then my spine collapsed
when I stepped on [ __ ] I stepped off a
curb and too hard and they they didn't
know what it was I like talking about
too much but they told me all different
kinds of things oh it's your muscles
it's their nerves it's in your head it's
in this and and I was limping for a few
years and people were always like how
are you doing I'm like I'll be alright
and you know cuz no one likes to hear
about anybody else and so and then then
when that happened they were like oh no
it's your bones I was like you mother
so everybody told me that you should go
so I started going to bone doctors and
everybody told me I should go see this
guy dr. Charles Sharpe and I called him
and he was expensive and he didn't take
insurance and so I was like well I'll go
to someone he trained so I'll go to
someone he trained I wouldn't get any
better after six months I go to someone
else he trained he went getting better
so if I was just about to die and I went
to hit to see him I like I was gonna pay
the money and go see him and he figured
out what it was like that anyway he says
when he goes you know no one in the know
where you go no one's gonna know where
that what this is I go yeah I know I've
already been everywhere and he said I
only saw this once before in 1968 and he
says and you have it yeah yeah so then
he causes it it was just of my my own
they didn't know at the time he thought
I was a tumor but they fit sense figured
out it was just my own bones leaching of
hormone that makes your body leach the
chemicals that I need to make bone so
anyway this is boring but no it's not
boring at all
so uh he fixed me and I start how did he
fix you he just diagnosed me what was
wrong and what I needed and so I need to
take supplements right for my bones to
make more like some people take calcium
so I take this thing called phosphorus
because you need phosphorous and calcium
and vitamin D to make bone right so that
we did that and it was amazingly you
know he's just an amazing doctor and
he's very right-wing as far as I can
tell right we he doesn't like to talk
politics but it comes up and he was in
the military and all this stuff and he's
just a great guy I just love he's so
smart
he's so smart and he fixed me so getting
back to when I was gonna kill myself so
when I left off the carbon I shrunk and
I was shrunk even more they did an
operation that gave me about an inch
back I was even shorter right so I'm
like holy [ __ ] and I'm like this is horn
this is like I wanted to kill my I was
literally gonna kill myself what was the
operation that did they had to put some
- slash steam mm-hmm so far some cement
they puff it up and then they stick
cement in it oh but I saw I was serious
I was like I cried one day I couldn't
stop I did I didn't know how to stop and
my eyes puffed up like I couldn't see
almost and I was gonna do I was like
I'll just kill myself and and the only
thing that kept me from not killing
myself was my manager called me and he
said hey I go you got that our special
on Comedy Central and I was like saved
your life I was like what talk about it
was the best of times it was the worst
of times I could not believe like what
and then I just knew I had to do this
special because I couldn't let all those
[ __ ] who said I wouldn't move
to LA and be a coma I couldn't let them
win it was about that it was about I'm
gonna show everybody who doubted me and
said I was crazy and good I'm gonna show
that I'm gonna do this goddamn special
it's gonna be [ __ ] awesome and then
I'll kill myself
and by the time so I had to get this
anyway long stories
I had to get this operation in my leg it
was the bo Jackson surgery you got a hip
replacement it was a PI
bond was diet dad dying and I went to so
my doctor sends me that this other
doctor who vented the operation at USC
and I walk into the office just like my
doctor predicted he's looking at my
chart and he looks up needles walked
I've only seen this in books meaning
what I have Wow and I was like that's
what dr. Sharpe said and so he was gonna
give me this operation he goes we're
gonna take this bone out from your chin
we're gonna put it in there and then you
can't step on that foot for six months
straight and I said I have a half-hour
special I'm taping in 8 months I go so I
can't do this operation he goes well
your thigh could just snap at any moment
I go I guess that's the chance I gotta
take
holy [ __ ] I can't do this special I'm
gonna kill myself anyway yeah give a
[ __ ] right so by the time we got to do
the special eight months later dr.
sharps treatment had kicked in and they
didn't know it was gonna fix it but it
fixed it
they're like it fixed it holy [ __ ] you
could have got that crazy operation and
nothing for nothing [ __ ] man so his
treatment is just supplements yeah yeah
yeah and you take that to this day every
day every time I eat I have to take two
did you alter your diet no he just he
tells me to make sure I eat meat because
I need the whatever it's in it I need
the stuff yeah
whatever whatever the good stuff is
he'll look at me like he goes you're
from Chicago right and I know yeah eat
me like that yeah [ __ ] plenty no so
you're not one of those are you
you
[Applause]